listen they simply will not stop another
ballot
audit is set to go forward in fulton
county georgia
and yes this is for the 2020
presidential election now
let's sit back for a second and review
yes
obviously joe biden won georgia yes
obviously even if biden lost georgia he
would still have the necessary 270
electoral votes to be president of the
united states
yes obviously the georgia results have
been certified
and confirmed and recounted and audited
for joe biden
multiple times and nothing can change
now and yes
obviously joe biden has been president
for months and this isn't
an absurd and humiliating fiasco for
republicans
but they will not stop cnn reports that
another ballot audit
or ardet as some say is set to move
ahead
in georgia's most populous county after
a judge ruled friday
that absentee ballots could be unsealed
for parties looking to examine them
for evidence of fraud georgia
republicans plan to bring in
sick so-called experts by the way
sometimes you see these experts and you
say dear god
they're going to bring in six experts to
look at the ballots
and see if they can determine whether
there are characteristics
pointing to counterfeit ballots now
remember
georgia counties already did the initial
count
a hand audit a rescan of each ballot and
every single one of those actions
confirmed that
joe biden won georgia you know who loves
this decision though
about doing another audit former
republican senator
kelly lefler from georgia who was
handily defeated by now democratic
senator rafael warnock she refers to him
as
radical liberal raphael warnock
she applauded this new audit saying
quote voter confidence in our election
system is the bedrock of our republic
unfortunately inconsistencies in fulton
county's november 2020 absentee ballots
cast serious doubt on voters faith in
our elections now one upside here just
for hilarity
is that they won't even be given the
real ballots to review i love this
they will be given scanned images of the
ballots
i don't know why i love that but they're
not even going to let them put their
hands on the actual ballots now
this wouldn't be so much an audit but an
attempt to tamper really
so it's probably smart not to give them
actual ballots but just the signed
images
and i read one commentary about this
that says
you know allowing this to go forward is
a mistake
because it's yet another seed of doubt
that gets planted in the minds of those
who want to believe this was stolen
something that might convince someone
that there was
fraud i think that that ship has long
sailed if you think there was fraud you
think there was fraud and none of this
stuff matters you just think there was
fraud
most people have moved on and another
pseudo-audit or forensic examination of
remember when they wanted to look at
bamboo fibers in arizona or whatever i
don't think it'll really make a
difference at this point in public
opinion
now um what is the latest that a judge
could even allow them to do something
like could you continue
auditing and reviewing ballots from 2020
beyond the 2022 mid midterms i have no
idea i don't know how long
it's possible for this to go on and of
course the troubling part
of all of this is you really can't prove
a negative and this is we've done a lot
of stories about
how conspiracy theories work and
conspiracism and conspiratorial thinking
when they find nothing for the second
time and the third time and the fourth
time in the fifth time
they instead of saying there's probably
nothing to find
they say you know they've done a really
good job of hiding it
if we did a sixth audit we would then
find the smoking gun that we're waiting
for
the fact that we've not found anything
in four reviews
is only evidence that they've hidden the
fraud really really well
and as i've said before healthy
skepticism is good
and thinking for ourselves is good and
understanding
what is the foundation of a belief how
did i come to believe a certain thing
that's all good never ending skepticism
if you never want to be satisfied you
can find a way to never be satisfied and
that's exactly what they are doing here
and
a real hallmark of conspiracy theorists
is that evidence for something counts as
evidence
and lack of evidence for that thing also
counts as evidence
because hiding the evidence is part of
the plan
and when you if you don't reason your
way
into a belief you're not going to get
reasoned out of it and i've said that
many times before and that's clearly a
case of what's going on here but
they're continuing to keep going that's
in georgia
and we also have some more interesting
news now out of arizona
most healthy granola bars have sort of a
bad reputation
because they're either dry or boring or
don't taste that good or
they don't satisfy your cravings but our
sponsor monk pack
is completely different because monk
pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture and yet
they have only 140 calories
one gram of sugar and only two to three
net carbs perfect
for the low sugar or keto diet they come
in
fantastic flavors like coconut cocoa
chip blueberry almond vanilla
and the new flavor peanut butter i've
been a fan for a long time i always have
them in my pantry
it is a perfect snack and if you don't
love them as much as i do
you get all your money back they also
now have a subscription feature which i
love it'll save you ten percent on every
order
and it ships automatically you'll get 20
off when you go to monkpack.com and use
the coupon code
pacman the link is right underneath this
video